)
- Depuis Bakhmout,
les bombardements de Soledar
sont visibles et audibles.
Ces deux localités de la région
de Donetsk, qu'une quinzaine
de kilomètres séparent,
sont devenues le théâtre
le plus sanglant de la guerre,
selon l'Ukraine.
- Moi, j'étais à Bakhmout
ce matin. 'a'a'a'avez quasiment
plus personne dans la rue.
Quasiment tous les immeubles
sont endommagés, détruits,
les façades calcinées.
- La ville de Soledar,
qui abritait les plus grandes
mines de sel d'Europe.
n'est désormais qu'un un champ
de ruine oùmimimimi-millier de
personnes ont décidé malgré tout
de rester. Pour la Russie,
Soledar demeure une prise
importante.
PIERREO,O,O,O,
journaliste indépendant
- La valeur stratégique de
Soledar vient de cet affront que
subit la Russie depuis des mois
papapapas arriver à s'emparer
d'une ville si petite.
JUSTIN MASSIE, Réseau d'analyse
ste,e,e,e,e, sc. po., UQÀM
- Il y a quand même certains
avantages, militaires aussi, qui
sont vus avec cette ville-là,
dans la mesure où ça permettra s
d'approvisionnement,
de logistique, notamment, pour
poursuivre l'offensive russe
de plus en plus à l'ouest
dans cette région.
- Cette prise est revendiquée
par les mercenaires du groupe
Wagner, et démentie par
l'Ukraine.
Le président Volodymyr Zelensky
a promis de fournir tout
le nécessaire à ses soldats
dans les deux villes.
- Les militaires ukrainiens à
qui j'ai parlé m'ont bien dit
qu'il y a des hommes de Wagner
et qu'ils avancent en direction
des positions ukrainiennes.
Ils se font... ils se font tuer
en nombre, à vrai dièèèèèès
ce que décrivent les Ukrainiens.
Mais en faisant ça,
ils permettent de révéler les
positions de tir ukrainiennes,
qui sont ensuite attaquées
par la deuxième ligne de Wagner.
- C'est une stratégie
extrêmement coûteuse, mais quive
de la Russie, qui est de miser
beaucoup sur les soldats,
un peu essentiellement
comme une chai......
- Un changement de tactique
militaire russe sur le terrain,
appuyé par la nomination
d'un nouveau général à la tête
du commandement militaire.
- Je pense que le changement
de garde, avec la promotion,
entre guillemets, du général
Guerassimov, signifie
un changement de tactique.
Parce que l'ancien général
avait un posture beaucoup
plus défen
- D'ailleurs, le renseignement
ukrainien redoute une offensive
russe dans les prochains mois.
Le pays compte consolider
ses positions grâce à l'armement
qu'il espère recevoir
de ses alliés.
- Les Ukrainiens, pour maintenir
leur intégrité territoriale
et libérer des zones qui sont
présentement sous occupation
russe, ont besoin de davantage
de sourerererererere, notamment
avec des blindés, notamment avec
d'autres soutien de défense
aérienne.
(coups de feu)
- À l'ouest, près de la
frontière bélarusse, des soldats
ukrainiens effectuent
des exercices milita
Un autre front à surveiller,
car plus de 10 000 soldats
russes y sont rassemblés.
Ici Yasmine Khayat,
Radio-Canada, Montréa